what will this take the average salary
at Goodwood to
I mean the average salary will increase
by around 16 I think for those on a
grade two it will be worth up to 17.6
and those on the grade seven it'll be
around 14.8 so yeah the average salary
really if we take a
if we take a Grade Three the top end of
a Grade Three they'll be getting 3 200
pounds just over Consolidated on the
first of January next year and likewise
they'll then get a a lump sum a
non-consolidated lump sum two thousand
pounds so if we're looking at that wage
I would say on the grade three around
just over 35 and a half thousand pounds
so it's a very positive settlement now
you led the negotiations how would you
characterize them
I would say that they were they were
difficult to start with I think that
certainly from from our point of view
we've been running an organizing
campaign for the past six or seven
months on the plant I think workers have
been responding to the message of our
general secretary Sharon Graham about
the renewed focus on jobs paying
conditions the new industrial priorities
so we've had a huge influx um to the
union from workers that no it was about
the time that they had a decent paywall
they work for an incredibly profitable
company I think the claim that went in
which was put together in consultation
with our members came in around an RPI
plus pay award there was obviously some
subsidiary elements to the claim around
ensuring that apprentices were part of
the pay deal for the first time and
likewise that the union would gain
oversight on the issuing of agency
contracts so yeah I think the the claim
was obviously quite High I think the
negotiations to start with we had a
variety of proposals that we knocked
back and we didn't feel that they went
anywhere near addressing the Mandate
that our members had given us during the
we had four days of negotiations one
month apart um two sets for two days and
during that uh sort of interim period we
were running a consulted ballot for
industrial action so we had 98 of our
members voted in favor of strike action
on the 74 turnout so we had a very
strong mandate when we reopened the
negotiations I think the companies saw
that their Workforce was serious about
getting um their Fair reward as they
contribute to massive profits and then
we got to a deal where we believe we you
know hit a genuine position that we
could agree to recommend it to our
membership via our ballot which was
taken to the plant in a referendum and
our members accepted it by 74 on an 84
turnout so it was a positive result so I
mean how close did it actually come to
strike action I mean it sounds like
obviously the members would have would
have gone that far have had it been
necessary it doesn't sound like it it
really reached that point from what you
said well yeah I think ultimately you
know we for us it's important that we
ensure that we have a a cast iron steer
from our members is to as to where they
want to go next should we not be able to
to meet their demands you know so
certainly I think we we had everything
ready if the company weren't going to
make an improved offer then we were
going to serve notice of a strike ballot
and I've no doubt that our members would
have responded with an overwhelming
mandate to proceed to to strike action
if this necessary so I think the company
recognized the strength of feeling on
the shop floor I think they recognize
the union its members were serious about
getting a decent payable this year but
also I think from the company's
perspective they recognize that their
work workers are in a unique situation
at the moment as they're trying to
address the cost living crisis that all
workers are facing across the economy so
I think the the negotiations were good
towards the end I think we got to a
position where we could recommend a deal
and obviously the the Reps have done a
fantastic job in negotiating a deal
alongside the union too so I think for
all parties it was good you know pay's
been delivered on time and it was a good
um a good end of the year you made an
interesting point there about the
approach of Rolls-Royce I mean obviously
Rolls-Royce Motors is owned by BMW of
Germany I mean unions and uh employers
are often seen as having quite a
collaborative relationship in in that
country do you think there's a lesson to
be learned here from the approach of
Rolls-Royce Motors
yeah I think ultimately we've got um
obviously there's a number of different
plants under the BMW group Banner in
this in this country you've got the
plant Oxford you've got plant Swindon
you've got Hans Hall and I think the
different plants have different cultures
I think certainly we've spent a long
time over the past year negotiating a
new recognition agreement that puts the
union a more even footing especially
when in terms of negotiating with the
company because we you know we need to
ensure that we negotiating from a
position of strength rather than
weakness and our members have kind of
responded to that so so yeah I think
there's probably things that we can
learn going forward from both parties
but again it's a positive outcome it's a
one-year deal you know so this time next
year we'll be negotiating again I think
we won't know at this moment in time
exactly we'll get economic content or
context will be but we're determined to
ensure that our Rolls-Royce members are
only the same as other car or workers in
the premium enter the sector so so yeah
I think it's it's positive work I think
the relationship with Rolls Royce at the
moment is good I think everyone's happy
that we've got a pay deal in place it's
going to be paid on time but again we'll
wait to see where we are around the sort
of September point and next year when we
submit the next claim but do you think
other employers could learn from how
Rolls-Royce Motors conducted themselves
with you in these negotiations
I think that ultimately both I mean the
negotiations themselves were cordial you
know there's not much table banging or
kind of theatrics of walking out you
know we're all trying to negotiate a
solution I think a lot of employers at
the moment are in a situation where
they're adopting varying transient
positions I think we've seen that in
other sectors of the economy at the
moment however you know any dispute can
be resolved but it needs both parties to
be prepared to negotiate and you know we
were fortunate enough to to have a set
of negotiations where Rolls Royce could
see that we were serious and likewise we
could understand when they said that we
kind of completely maxed out where we
can go to
um so yeah I think both parties
recognize that the negotiations were an
end and then for us as a union we have
to make a recommendation whether people
vote to accept or reject that and I felt
that
certainly from the negotiations that
we've had we'd hit a clear kind of
Deadlock in the sense that we got full
of fun off from the company um you know
at that point it needs to go back before
the membership they need to determine
what we do next and likewise the Reps at
two and we felt that we we got to a good
recommended position on the pay deal
that does something to protect our
protect our members at this moment in
time